hi I'm Sophie Tana and today I'm doing
an interview with puppies come on oh
yeah nope yeshuaa
thank you my favorite part about filming
Dark Phoenix was probably I don't know
probably just okay all right you know
what you remind me of my husband my
favorite part was probably hanging out
with the cast and and seeing Simon
Kinberg who has been the writer for so
many years finally kind of step into the
Oh to the director's chair that was my
favorite part and we we as a cast in
just kind of like a family and the crew
were all so close so that's always my
favorite part is going back to them I
would like teleportation I think
teleporter hey come here honey
oh are you looking for your friend I
wouldn't teleportation became it he
clearly has that power of teleportation
teleporting right out of him oh yes I
would like to you know go to link Tokyo
for lunch or something
gene is very vulnerable and Sansa is
incredibly strong and resilient yes so I
would say I wish I was like Sansa but
really I'm probably a bit more like Jean
I'm more kind of I don't know I take a
lot of inspiration from Sansa jeana's
more vulnerable and kind of finding her
identity and I think I relate to that
[Music]
I hope it would be you know she would
live in harmony and with with you know
all of the lords and ladies of the north
and I would hope that she had it had a
nice life but I somehow I doubt that
yeah you do too you doubt it I would
hope that she she would live happily
ever after and I don't think she'd have
another man in her life because they
haven't treated her particularly well in
the past so I I would like to think that
she just runs the north on her own and
eats good food and drinks good wine and
just has a good time I balance it by you
know trying to keep in touch with all of
my school friends that I've known since
I was like two or three they're kind of
my only friends are the ones that I've
known since I was really really really
young so that's kind of how I stay
down-to-earth and also I have two older
brothers that are just you know though
like occasionally try and beat me up and
stuff like that as older brothers do so
that definitely keeps you kind of
free-spirited and down to earth
oh my personal favorite TV shows I love
Barry I love Barry it's so funny what
else do I love killing Eve killing even
Barry and my favorites right now and I
also I just love anything like true
crime I love anything like that which is
probably why I like Barry even though
it's not true crime but it's about you
know an assassin or whatever so that's
fun but if you haven't watch Barry you
should totally go and watch it it's
amazing and Bill Hader is phenomenal in
it yes she is I mean a physical fight
gene would win but I think stars are
good
emotionally manipulate gene probably I
think gene would win just because she's
the most powerful mutant in the universe
and could obliterate anyone in a second
we have kind of a history of mental
health problems and my family which is
always fun so you know it's always been
a big part of my life and you know I've
nearly lost people too to mental health
problems that I really care about and so
it's always been for me about D
stigmatizing that and bringing it into
the norm and not feel ashamed and feel
okay to kind of reach out and get help
and that's something that I just feel
more passionately about than anything
Jessica Chastain is a troublemaker so
you would think I was terrified to meet
her because you're not really supposed
to meet your idols that's what people
say and she's just one of the greatest
actors out there right now so I was
terrified but she is a lot of fun I
thought she was gonna be a bit uptight
and you know actory but she's not she
likes to dance and sing on set and play
pranks she pulls a lot of pranks
actually she's the biggest prankster on
set for sure there was a production
meeting that she that Simon Kinberg was
having with all of kind of the Fox
executives and she hired a mariachi band
to go into that meeting and told them to
not stop playing for half an hour no
matter how much they beg so I think that
might have gotten into a bit of trouble
but it was funny I don't know
oh my favorite book is the psychopathy
test by Jon Ronson he's my favorite
author of all time I think he's
wonderful and he has such incredible
stories to tell him he's lived such an
interesting life Weller I use a lot of
Wella products on my hair because I have
to you know do so much to it change it
diet curl it straighten it so that kind
of keeps it healthy and keeps the blonde
in facially I used this great is skin
equals cleanser lemare moisturizer and
truth serum look you Superman whoo these
dogs were provided by Vanderpump dogs
and you can go to their website
Vanderpump dogs org
[Music]
[Music]